hey this is presh talwalker there's a
famous false proof that Pi is equal to
zero and the starting point is Euler's
identity
e to the I pi plus 1 is equal to zero
where e is Euler's number the base of
natural logarithms approximately equal
to 2.718 I is the imaginary unit where I
squared is equal to negative 1 and Pi is
the ratio of the circle's circumference
to its diameter
so we'll use this equation as the
starting point e to the I pi plus 1 is
equal to zero
subtract 1 from both sides so e to the I
Pi is equal to negative one
Square both sides of the equation
e to the I pi squared is equal to e to
the two I pi and negative 1 squared is
equal to one
so e to the two I Pi is equal to one
multiply both sides of the equation by e
and then add the exponents on the left
hand side so we have e to the power of
2i pi plus one is equal to E
we'll start at this equation and
continue our analysis
now we know that e is equal to e to the
power of 2i pi plus 1. so where we have
an e here in the base we can substitute
in E is equal to e to the power of 2i pi
plus 1.
so we have e to the power of 2i pi plus
one that term raised to the exponent of
2i pi plus 1. and that is equal to E
now we will multiply the exponents so we
have e to the power of 2i pi plus 1
multiplied by two I pi plus 1 and that
is equal to E
so let's simplify this exponent
we have 2i pi plus 1 multiplied by
itself so we're going to square this
binomial we can expand it out
this will be 2i Pi the term squared plus
four I pi plus 1 squared
so we get 4 pi squared multiplied by I
squared plus 4i pi plus 1.
now I squared is equal to negative one
so this is negative 4 pi squared plus 4
I pi plus 1. so we can substitute that
into the exponent so we have e to the
power of negative 4 pi squared plus four
I pi plus 1 is all equal to E
so now we're going to break up the
exponents so this is equal to e to the
power of negative 4 pi squared
multiplied by e to the power of 4i pi
multiplied by e to the power 1 and
that's all equal to E
now e to the power of 1 is equal to e so
we can cancel this out on both sides
so we have e to the power of negative 4
pi squared multiplied by e to the power
of 4 I Pi is equal to 1. so what is e to
the power of four I Pi this is equal to
cosine of 4 pi plus I times sine of 4 pi
cosine of 4 Pi is equal to 1 and sine of
4 Pi is equal to 0. so e to the power of
4 I pi simplifies to be 1.
so we end up with e to the power of
negative 4 pi squared is equal to 1.
we're getting very close
we'll take the natural log of both sides
and now the natural log of 1 is equal to
zero and we can bring the exponent down
on the left hand side so we have
negative 4 pi squared multiplied by the
natural log of e is equal to zero the
natural log of e is equal to one this
gives negative four pi squared is equal
to zero dividing both sides by negative
four we get that pi squared is equal to
zero and therefore Pi is equal to zero
so we've come up with an absurd
conclusion but every single step
seemingly was true
so where is the mistake how can we end
it up with pi is equal to zero
I'll carefully explain where the mistake
happens and then I will show the proper
way you're supposed to do complex
exponentiation to avoid these kinds of
contradictions
so here we have one step where e to the
power of 2i pi plus 1 raised to the
power of two I pi plus 1 is equal to E
the next step is that e raised to the
power of two I pi plus 1 multiplied by
itself is equal to E
so it's between these two steps that the
mistake happens
so the first equation is actually true
you can input this into Wolfram Alpha
for example and you can see that e to
the power of 2i pi plus 1 that term
raised to the power of 2i pi plus one is
actually equal to e so this equation is
true
but the next equation is not true e to
the power of 2i pi plus 1 multiplied by
itself is not actually equal to e if you
put this in you'll see that this is
approximately equal to zero it's going
to be e to the power of 1 minus 4 pi
squared so this is where the mistake
happens is saying that the first
equation implies the second
so where does our intuition go wrong so
we are taught these exponent power rules
that a to the power of B all raised to
the power of C is equal to a to the
power of BC
this rule may not be true for complex
exponents so sometimes you can use this
and it will work but it may not be true
and you can see the problem when you use
this rule with complex exponents you can
go from one equation that's true to
another equation that's false
so what is the proper way to evaluate
complex exponents it's a bit tricky but
it's important to go through the step so
that you avoid contradictions
so if you have a complex number Z raised
to a power w
this is supposed to be defined as e to
the power of w multiplied by the natural
log of Z
so how does this work in our particular
example so in this case the base Z is e
to the power of 2i pi plus 1 and we're
raising that to the power W where W is
equal to 2i pi plus 1.
so if we use the definition of complex
exponentiation
this will be equal to e to the power of
2i pi plus 1 multiplied by the natural
log of e to the power of 2i pi plus 1.
now this is where we have to be a bit
careful so e to the power of 2i pi plus
1 we know is equal to e so here we have
the value of e and then the natural
logarithm of e is of course equal to 1.
so this works out to be e to the power
of 2i pi plus 1. and we know that this
is equal to e by carefully applying the
definition of complex exponentiation
we've simplified the left hand side of
the equation to be equal to e and that
is equal to the right hand side of the
equation which is equal to e so e is
equal to E
well that's a boring result but we have
not created any contradictions like Pi
is equal to zero now that you understand
the definition of complex exponentiation
the careful viewer will start pointing
out all sorts of other mistakes so
actually earlier in the proof we had e
to the power of I pi squared and we just
multiplied the exponents and said that's
equal to e to the power of 2i Pi
this does work out to be true the left
hand side is equal to one and the right
hand side is equal to one however by the
formal definition of complex
exponentiation we're not supposed to be
multiplying these exponents together it
doesn't always work out
so to reveal we have the power rule for
real numbers if we have e to the power
of X raised to the power of Y you can
just multiply the exponents you have e
to the power of x times y but when you
have complex numbers you can't do this
so if you have e to the power of X
raised to the power of Y it's actually
equal to e to the power of Y multiplied
by the natural log of e to the power of
x
so in real numbers the natural log of e
to the power of X is always equal to X
but this may not always be true with
complex numbers so in our particular
example we had the natural log of e to
the power of 2i pi plus 1 and we showed
this was actually equal to one it's not
equal to two I pi plus 1.
so when you're doing complex
exponentiation you want to be careful
and use the definition and apply it so
that you avoid horrible mistakes like Pi
is equal to zero
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
[Music]